el acuerdo conocido como aucus incluye
la compra por parte de Australia de tres
submarinos de propulsión nucleares de
Estados Unidos en la década de 2030 con
la opción de adquirir dos más si es
necesario también se desplegará una
fuerza de submarinos estadounidenses y
británicos en Australia occidental para
ayudar a entrenar a las tripulaciones
australianas y reforzar la disuasión el
aumento de la actividad militar de china
en el mar de China meridional el cual
reclama como suyo ha generado tensiones
con Estados Unidos china ha rechazado El
pacto y lo ha calificado como un acto
ilegal de proliferación nuclear
Australia también recibió críticas de
Francia por cancelar un acuerdo previo
para la compra de submarinos
convencionales de ese país a pesar de
esto los líderes de los tres países han
destacado los beneficios económicos y
laborales para Australia y Gran Bretaña
y la importancia de asegurar la paz y la
estabilidad en la región indopacífico
este acuerdo es histórico pues es la
primera vez que Estados Unidos comparte
tecnología de propulsión nuclear desde
la década de 1950 cuando se asoció con
Gran Bretaña